[Music]
happy holidays from Honest Trailers
we'll be back in two weeks with some of
this year's biggest hits but until then
here's a bunch of oh crap we strung
together for you to watch instead of
connecting with friends and family
[Music]
from the once masterful director who
just couldn't leave well enough alone
comes the special effects Blockbuster
that transformed the entire film
industry into an assembly line for
special effects Blockbusters and action
figures Star Wars the first one
we are not calling it a New Hope right
along with some of film's most iconic
characters surrounded by film's most
iconic props and designs in some of the
most iconic locations ever to the point
where every single person place her
thing on screen has at least a 1 000
word Wikipedia article about it did you
know that these guys are called jizz
Whalers
Whalers meet Heroes like Princess Leia
the most interesting of the two human
females in the entire movie Han Solo a
real Han Solo type Obi-Wan a wise Jedi
Master who doesn't remember the Droid
that saved his life several times I
don't seem to remember ever owning a
drawing the droids conscious beings with
feelings and Free Will who were bought
and sold as slaves do you think they'll
melt us down please please don't
deactivate me hashtag Droid lives matter
guys and Luke Skywalker a whiny space
brat when I was going into Tashi Station
to
pick up it reminds me of someone it's
all Obi-Wan's fault there's nothing I
can do about it right now I hate them
but they're gonna kill her it's not fair
it just isn't fair wait so Hayden
christensen's acting choices were
intentional whoa mind blown together
they'll go on one of the most epic space
journeys of all time they would have
been totally unnecessary if anyone had
email I've placed information vital to
the survival of the Rebellion into the
memory systems of this R2 unit to take
on the evil empire with an army of
clumsy idiots
led by the most threatening villain of
all time Darth Vader until you hear his
original voice
I want them alive not so epic now are
you bro return to a time when technology
forced George Lucas to collaborate with
other people as he teams up with Masters
and sound design score editing and
practical visual effects to deliver a
near Perfect movie that he's made
progressively worse with each special
edition because if there's one thing the
original Star Wars wasn't missing it's
poorly rendered out of place CGI animals
filling up every square into The Fray
dude come on get out of the way ah I
can't even see the movie relive all the
parts your Nostalgia goggles keep you
from admitting we're kind of dumb like
this guy in a Bargain Bin werewolf mask
the lightsaber battle where two old
geezers gently poke at each other and
the most over-the-top Freudian finale of
all time Luke is the best pushed pilot
in the outer rim territories look at the
size of that thing
should be able to penetrate the outer
defense
look at that speed would be able to pull
out in time that's what she said
so whether you're an old man who can
move on from a 38 year old movie for
children or a contrarian kid who thinks
he's being edgy when he says the
prequels were better one thing is for
sure Han shot first
starring
Skywalkers in flight
Beats By Braid Star Ford genuine class
dog is my co-pilot Weezer Porkins oh
that's just mean an Oscar and a trash
can Satan blue milk and Nazis in space
Joseph Campbell Star Wars
as bad as we all want a real lightsaber
let's be realistic we cut off our own
hand in a week
[ __ ]
the greatest film of the original
trilogy one of the best sequels ever
made and the movie Star Wars fans love
the most just so happens to be the one
where George Lucas was involved the
least hmm The Empire Strikes Back you
love the fun-filled space adventure
where evil is vanquished and everyone
gets a medal yay now watch the Rebellion
get crushed the comic relief get Frozen
and the ultimate Evil tell the hero
who's your Daddy I am your father in a
sequel so dark it's become the lazy
shorthand for any time a franchise turns
even slightly to the dark side
yeah well this is actually The Empire
Strikes Back Up on its trailers so there
yeah
witness a movie full of excellent
directing great acting brilliant
dialogue why are you stuck up
half-witted
gorgeous music and iconic moments that
will stay with you for a lifetime I love
you
I know but uh let's see what the nitpick
here uh sometimes they pronounce Han
Solo's name different what about Han get
up here do you think that after what you
did
you suck Perfect movie ah this is gonna
be a tough one isn't it revisit all of
your favorite characters three years
after they shut their balls into the egg
hole like Princess Leia whose proof that
Lucas either didn't have these movies
planned out as much as he claims or he
was into some pretty weird stuff Han
Solo a Charming Smuggler who's not
afraid to make a point with his hands no
uh I can arrange that put them back
together ignore Commander Skywalker
that's right my friends out in it wait a
second that's what you punches turn her
around stand by the manual at least
and Luke Skywalker the magical moisture
farmer who's no longer a whiny brat now
he's just dumb whether he's crashing his
ex-wing into a swab getting tricked into
a hole running out of a warm cake to
freeze to death losing a fight to slow
moving pieces of furniture
or ignoring the advice of the last
living Jedi you must complete the
training I can't keep the vision out of
my head they're my friends I gotta help
them well at least they have a spare
in a world where sequels and reboots
Coast by on Nostalgia alone enjoy a
sequel that takes everything you love
about Star Wars and actually Builds on
it adding all new worlds like hot a
planet made of ice Dagobah a planet made
of snakes and bespin a planet made of
mad paintings each one of them full of
amazing all new characters like Lando
Calrissian a gambler who won a mining
company in a card game I think Boba Fett
the biggest movie Badass with the least
amount of screen time and of course Yoda
the Jedi Master who trains Luke in the
ancient art of uh entering spooky caves
not trying anything there is no try and
flipping for no reason wait a second
these pointless gymnastics remind me of
someone
that's where the prequels got all the
dump flipping around from whoa mind
blown so strap in for the Star Wars
movie that's so good they barely touched
it in the special editions representing
the absolute loot peak of the franchise
when the prequels could still be good
then we go back 20 years and we do the
story of young Darth Vader and young the
young Alec Guinness character and in the
third film which precedes Star Wars you
see like a prequel that's right they had
an actual end date in sight if Lucas
makes all nine episodes the force may be
around until
2001. and people didn't take these
make-believe characters so freaking
seriously Han Solo and Princess Leia and
uh and The Wookie and the C three cpoos
starring The Wookie three CPO Cool Hand
Luke Rey's mom ran or something hand
Point O worst Kinder egg ever adulthish
Gambino the dude from the holiday
special the hardest level in the Rogue
Squadron N64 game and run run run jump I
can be your backpack while you run The
Empire Strikes Back of Star Wars
no like father like son I guess
[Music]
[Music]
a new hoe blew people's minds The Empire
Strikes Back challenged what you thought
a sequel could be now the last chapter
of the original trilogy takes its place
in history as the third one Star Wars
Return of the Jedi from creative
Visionary George Lucas and once
Spielberg Lynch and Cronenberg passed
the cheapest director he could find
comes a film that had to live up to
impossibly high expectations and said
screw it we're making a kids movie full
of burp gags
slapstick comedy and Boba Fett going out
like Wiley Coyote
in a finale that's almost silly enough
to make you question why your identity
is so tied to a soap opera about space
Wizards human
ity
that's it I'm a Trekkie now what does
what did God need with a Starship
never mind all your favorite Heroes have
returned like Luke who's grown from
naive Farm Boy to goth Catholic priest
Han who was already so over Star Wars
they had him Frozen in case he didn't
bother to show up Leia who suddenly
Luke's sister I don't know
somehow
I've always known you have well that
makes this extra weird then plus an
all-new cast of memorable characters
like uh her salacious crumbs kind of fun
and
um
Gronk
sure why not before there was jar jar
the object of fans blind rage was the
Ewoks a race of cuddly creatures
inspired by puppy dogs Bear Cubs and toy
sales who Lucas loved so much they got
two spin-off movies two
[Music]
the Discerning fans hated because
there's no way the mighty Empire would
struggle against a smaller poorly Armed
Force what do you think this is Vietnam
Afghanistan Little Bighorn the American
Revolution the Maori Ethiopia
Afghanistan again
set aside a special place in hell where
Jedi special edition that not only adds
the same bad CG as the other two but
tons of crap that's only there to remind
you of the prequels like gun guns
extra nose
[Applause]
Hayden christensen's and the criminal
Erasure of the yubnub song
an entire generation will grow up with
that awful Jedi Rocks number but never
know the Brilliance of John Williams
song
for shame
so return to Star Wars with Return of
the Jedi a movie that joins Godfather 3
Terminator 3 and Spider-Man 3 in the
tradition of May 3rd installments that
turned an epic about the fate of the
Galaxy into the Skywalker family drama
cemented the kid-friendly tone of the
franchise
and set up Star Wars long-running love
affair with the plot of a new hope the
battle station the emperor's new battle
station the droid control ship
Starkiller base we're starting our
attack run stay alert we could run out
of space real fast
going in we're going in
yeah it's like poetry so if they rhyme
every stanza kind of rhymes with the
last one
hopefully it'll work yep
it did
starring my midi coracle romance I've
got a bored feeling about this Sunny D
Williams ball sack Force Man Captain
fetzma Sister Sister ghost dad harmonica
solo
Teddy sucks been
this little guy Parliament trunkadelic
and slug life
Star Wars 3 episode 6 out of nine
possibly 12.
just a word of advice to Daisy Ridley if
you see Lucas talking to the Wardrobe
Department run
before solo milks your Nostalgia for the
original trilogy dry discover three
spin-offs that took everything you loved
about the old Star Wars movies
I love you I know and gave you something
uh let's just say different
whip
original Star Wars spin-offs
kickoff an evening of crap with Caravan
of Courage the Ewok movie Set before the
other Ewok movie but after the movie
that was 30 Ewok embark on an adventure
with no one's favorite unblinking murder
pairs as they team up with another
creature that's better in small doses a
kid I think they want to be our friends
together they'll search for her missing
parents with her brother maze a
Skywalker knockoff with a hair of Luke
and the acting of Anakin it looks like
the monster is
and of course Tinkerbell I think
[Music]
planting the seeds of that Disney buyout
really early huh
if Caravan of Courage is The Hobbit then
get ready cause Battle of Endor is Game
of Thrones without question the darkest
Star Wars movie ever made where most of
the Ewoks are slaughtered in the opening
scene the four-year-old's whole family
is massacred my family
she's kidnapped by a dragon and has to
spend the rest of her life getting
yelled at by Wilford Brimley I don't
want you here get out what get out
that'll screw up someone for Life holy
crap this is a captain phasma prequel
isn't it
but those are just warm-ups for the main
event watch the original Star Wars
Trilogy lose its final tread of dignity
in the Star Wars holiday special a
project so bad George Lucas wanted to
destroyed forever and that guy made
attack of the Clones wow
what do you know sit through this
vaguely Star Wars themed variety show
where the only variety is the level of
drugs they were on when they wrote it
whether it's a song from most Eisley
canteen owner B Arthur just one more
round friends
a song from 70s soft rock Titans
Jefferson Starship
from Princess Leia while Harrison Ford
regrets all of his life choices
[Music]
now that's the face of a man who has a
really bad feeling about this in between
the talent sections enjoy a tiny scrap
of story tying it all together where
Chewie has to get home to his beloved
itchy Mala and lumpy for Life day which
is like Christmas but Harry and vaguely
Wiccan
the Empire is on high alert thanks to an
overdub scene from a new hope I want the
rebels located and identified but with
no help from Luke where's Chewbacca no
help from Leah send either Chewbacca or
Han Solo to the screen please and actual
help from one half of The Honeymooners
aren't corny I brought you that proton
Packer you know
what you might call it the the
thingamabob Chewie's family will spend
over an hour horrifically groaning at
each other while you try to maintain
your last shred of sanity
hello
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so melt your brain with three Star Wars
films so awful you'll never complain
about the prequels The Last Jedi or solo
again
because no matter what Disney decides to
throw what is next there's no way it
will be as bad as Chewie's dad watching
VR porn in the middle of the living room
did I did I just dream that oh no no
there it is that was real ah we are
excited aren't we oh geez turn it off
turn it off
[Music]
story Muppet baby at least Warwick Davis
got paid You're a hairy wizard diabetes
Origins those are awful good pies
Best I Ever Had Maleficent Wilfred
Brimley dropping the F-bomb in a TV
movie for children
[ __ ] Jefferson Star Destroyer Malibu
Luke Carrie Fisher giving zero shots
lumpy space Prince and he did it all for
the wookie
Star Wars the first sellouts
you know the weirdest thing about these
movies it's the first appearance of Boba
Fett and it's awesome I
I don't follow me friend why settle down
all they do is eat
[Music]
the greatest Saga of all time was ruined
by this film
from the billion dollar jowls of George
Lucas comes the chance to relive the
biggest letdown in movie history in 3D
all the parts you forgot about like the
bureaucratic conversations this Trail is
not recognize the senator from the Trade
Federation at this time the racism
Natalie Portman's weird robot voice will
not condone a course of action that will
lead us to war more races I was not
aware
and this kind of anti-Semitic thing only
money in 3D so strap yourself in and get
ready for an hour and a half of people
standing in semi-circles Council
meetings different Council meetings and
sitting just to get to five minutes of
cool stuff during Oscar Schindler as
Jesus fake Yoda and you so remember
himself
this February George Lucas defiles your
childhood for a second time in the third
dimension
Star Wars Episode 1 The Phantom Menace
3D cause George Lucas has to shot
somewhere
[Music]
from the man who created some of your
fondest childhood memories then took a
huge dump on him comes the prequel
sequel that proved Phantom Menace wasn't
an accident this isn't how it's supposed
to be Star Wars Episode 2 attack of the
Clones once again the Republic is in
turmoil watch as the chin stroking Jedi
are pulled into a war between a
completely disposable droid army and a
completely disposable Clone Army
seriously there's no reason to get
emotionally involved in any of this crap
experience an awkward forced love story
as Solas as the computer it was made in
with so many visual effects the
filmmakers didn't have any time left
over for things like realistic
choreography realistic dialogue I'm
haunted by the kiss
that you should never have given me or
realistic Hayden Christensen acting I
don't like sand
of course
rough and irritating and it gets
everywhere
not like you come on JJ there is no way
you can do any worse than this Natalie
Portman and her space air return as
Senator Padme Amidala went to the
Galaxy's best Sharp Shooting assassins
tried to kill her with a poisonous worm
pooping robot two Jedi Warriors will
come to her Aid Obi-Wan Kenobi A man
forced to act opposite lifeless CGI
characters like Hayden Christensen and
Anakin Skywalker
a red-tailed [ __ ] who's been creepily
stalking Padme for the last decade I've
thought about her every day since we've
parted I don't think she liked me
watching her I'd much rather dream about
Padme you're exactly the way I remember
you in my dreams please don't look at me
like that
it makes me feel uncomfortable
[Music]
sorry my lady
ugh
ride along with these one-dimensional
Heroes and a movie so unevenly paced
you'll have to wait over an hour before
you even meet the main villain instead
strap yourself in for even more of the
stuff that made Phantom Menace so cold
lifeless and boring like people sitting
and talking standing and talking walking
and talking one person standing and
talking while another is sitting and
talking people standing and talking then
taking a seat for more talking and a
whole bunch of wipes
[Music]
foreign
hey don't act again you in a bad movie
yogurt and bison nippley Portman
Lawrence fishberg definitely not the
emperor [ __ ] Cthulhu Darth Saruman
and Django unbrained Star Wars episode
11 attack of the Clones
so correct me if I'm wrong here but the
Clones never actually attack anyone in
this movie so why the [ __ ] would you
call this movie a tag of the Clones
[Music]
from Disney's bitter ex-boyfriend comes
the finale of The Saga so bad this
ridiculous overactive disappointing mess
is known as the good one
Star Wars Revenge of the Sith return to
a Time long ago when there was still
hope that the prequels could stick The
Landing with a film that starts out
semi-promising this is where the fun
begins then Falls flat on its stupid
face
watch Star Wars finish its turn to the
dark side as everything you've grown to
hate returns midichlorians younglings
and
cringe as Anakin Skywalker completes his
journey from Annoying kid to obnoxious
teenager to insufferable Jedi knight in
her performance so robotic his body
finally catches up to his acting
although to be fair no one can make this
drag sound natural love won't save you
Padme only my new powers can do that
Natalie Portman is back and she's just
kind of there weep as this once proud
Queen Senator and Warrior spends the
whole movie barefoot and pregnant and I
want to have our baby back home on the
boo I can go early and fix up the baby's
room and finally witness what the whole
trilogy has been building to Anakin
Skywalker becoming Darth Vader watch the
greatest movie villain of all time turn
evil because he's passed up for a
emotion we do not Grant you the rank of
Master has a bad dream about his secret
wife commits Jedi's side when an old man
gives him a super vague promise about
cheating death then gets burned to a
crisp because his teacher is standing on
a hill it's over Anakin I have The High
Ground so Darth Vader is a whiny dumb
easy to manipulate lap dog who got his
suit because he couldn't quite jump high
enough mystery solved thanks for
clearing that up George experience the
best Star Wars prequel by default simply
because something occasionally happens
even if that something is a lizard
chasing a robot on a unicycle but don't
worry fans of sitting and talking
because every time things start to get
interesting George Lucas gives us some
of the shittiest talkiest scenes in the
trilogy featuring Council meetings
picture of General Grievous will end
this war therapy sessions close to
yes commutes with all due respect muster
is he not the chosen one
weird bubble shows I don't think Anakin
and just staring out of the window
all slowly building up to the most
obvious reveal of all time that the evil
Sith Lord is the Sinister old guy who
talks exactly like the evil Sith Lord oh
gasp not the guy who does four evil head
turns in one conversation and the Jedi
don't
PA
life from dying
not from a Jedi what a Twist after two
pointless wheel spinning movies watch a
finale where Anakin goes from peaceful
Jedi to child murdering Maniac in less
than 10 minutes it's not the Jedi way
he must live there are too many of them
what are we going to do
followed by 20 minutes of George Lucas
jamming everyone into their New Hope
starting positions even if it ruins the
franchise continuity like how did Leia
remember her mom's face she was
very beautiful why didn't Obi-Wan
remember Leia that boy is our last hope
there is another how did Owen and Peru
age 40 years in 20 years why does all
the Galaxy's technology look like it got
worse and how can we ever take Darth
Vader seriously again after we've seen
this
no
is Right starring the following proof
that more does not equal better one
ham-handed Cameo goodbye Chewbacca two
disposable CGI armies two cyborgs with
breathing problems four lightsabers at
the same time four unnecessary CGI
flippy jobs
eight severed limbs
about 17 things R2D2 couldn't do in the
original and thousands of highly trained
Jedi Knights going down like total pogs
seriously you can cut through droids and
clones like tissue paper and that's how
you go out that sounds pathetic man
Star Wars episode 111 the force awakens
if you think the movie was bad wait
until you see what they cut out it's
broken
can you understand what he's saying I'm
pretty sure that beep is down oh yes yes
yes you're right beep is up
[Music]
you've spent weeks arguing about the
Mandalorian you'll spend months arguing
about the rise of Skywalker now watch
The One Star Wars movie capable of
uniting the entire fan base by agreeing
it's the worst theatrically released
movie in the franchise
easily Star Wars the Clone Wars the
movie the show is a different story gear
up for a movie based on a vague
reference to something Mark Hamill said
in 1977. you fought in the Clone Wars
yes but since the Samurai Jack guy made
them look Kick-Ass one time lucasfilm
followed up with a poorly animated kids
movie
really poorly animated I'd best be on my
way
like so poorly animated every scene ends
with the same animation of someone
crossing their arms
foreign
did they forget to render this looks
like an educational Star Wars spin-off
game designed to teach me how to type
your favorite prequel characters are
back yay like Anakin Skywalker who's
only killed sand people at this point
not younglings so he's good Obi-Wan who
took all the stiffness out of his
personality and transferred it to his
hair Christopher Lee and Sam Jackson who
didn't get the memo they could skip this
one I need three of his star Cruisers
a bunch of nameless clones thanks for
the ride Rex Cody battle positions oh
don't name your clones man you're just
gonna get attached Ahsoka Tano a
sidekick built out of corporate memos to
make a cool young girl Jedi who's cool
and does cool stuff you're stuck with me
Sky guy what did you just call me and
baby Yoda zigzag opposite stinky
oh stinky you're a mistake no one will
ever speak up again
begun the Clone Wars have and boring the
Clone Wars are because this is 90 solid
minutes of droid shooting at clones
clones shooting at droids and space
Wizards flipping around in the middle of
it all helping the Clone shoot the
droids more better but since we know the
same guy is running both armies we know
this is all a big distraction that means
absolutely nothing unless you're the guy
who owns the right to the Blaster sound
effect in that case chi-ching am I right
foreign
for the first Star Wars set entirely
inside an actual star war that somehow
more boring than the holiday special at
least that had Wookies watching VR porn
still it does feature the greatest
Redemption story in Star Wars no not
that guy Dave filoni who somehow shook
off this mess and turned it into
multiple compelling seasons of
television turned this Brad into one of
the most popular characters in The
fandom and prove that there's room for
more than one Hollywood nerd in a cowboy
hat El Mariachi versus the Mandalorian
guys at least give it some thought
starring Darth later poochie a good
movie now that's a thing I haven't made
in a long time Padme I'm a dead eyes Mr
and Mrs Sith BattleBots and babies look
PS2 Jedi power battles
so this is around 20 years before A New
Hope and jizz music hasn't changed at
all are these guys playing brand new
Cutting Edge jizz or does the most
Eisley Cantina have a retro GIS theme
back when we thought the prequels would
be the last Star Wars stuff we would
ever get time thanks I don't like sound
[Applause]
one animator stood against the darkness
answer to hell with making the force
balanced I'm gonna make it jacked
Gandy tartikovsky's Clone Wars look
we'll do the Clone Wars TV series
eventually okay it just ended for
sheep's sake Kira for the original
adaptation of the throwaway line of
dialogue in A New Hope you fought in the
Clone Wars there's no longer Canon
because they already replaced it because
we're so crammed full of Star Wars crap
now they're already rebooting the
spin-offs and it's a shame because even
though these animated shorts were made
to promote a movie that wasn't very good
they are totally
completely hugely
balls to the wall
exhausting to watch in one sitting man
this is a lot of action can we pause for
a Little Star Wars dialogue in there
Annie you're almost a Jedi Knight and
then and then what Jedis aren't supposed
to be married never mind let's just get
the lightsabers rooming again
oh yeah that's this stuff all the Jedi
you love are back Anakin is somehow even
whinier but I am the best pilot in the
order Chancellor Palpatine knows it I
don't know why you can't Padawan Obi-Wan
is a real piece of sass seems I've
created quite the mess now haven't I
what an incredible smell you've
discovered Sam Jackson is probably
pissed off he voiced this Clone Wars
Mace Windu this is a dark day for the
Republic instead of this Clone Wars Mace
Windu
and Yoda is doing his best Rin and
Stimpy impression
[Applause]
[Music]
together they'll lead an army of clones
against hordes of killer droids using a
wide range of tactics like charging
straight into them at full speed
and nope that's it
[Music]
man the Jedi were bad generals the
Clones would have ordered 66 and with or
without Palpatine
returned to a tie when the dark side was
gathering its forces but she wasn't
ready to make a move yet which means
these Clone Wars are chocked full of
Dooku
a villain destined to train bad guys who
are way cooler than he is like this
unnamed murder lady a force user so
badass she got a name in the reboot well
done adventurous mattress General
Grievous and Unstoppable combination of
Michael Myers and a dustbuster and a
collection of super cool randos you'll
get pissed off you never got an action
figure of I mean seriously new gun ray
is a toy but we didn't get a Hell's
Angel jousting Droid what about third
Act of Akira Guy where is my articulated
Wolf Man Jedi
so strap in as your favorite sci-fi Riff
on Old Samurai movies gets riffed on by
a guy famous for his sci-fi Samurai
cartoon and by Rift on I mean he just
did a long Samurai Jack episode with
lightsabers that kept Star Wars alive
after the prequel schools inspired your
favorite stuff about the new Canon and
gave us the best ending in the Star Wars
franchise Anakin getting tribal tats
from a space leech while they talk about
entering a mom's mouth to save the Navy
enter the mother's mouth to awake her in
a flame what story
My Little Pony magic friendship is you
have his coordinates then plug them in
hyperspace tracking oh man Last Jedi
ruined this movie too like selling
semester Monday these squid guys have a
dong and balls on the back of their
heads it flops in everything C3 peep
show
[Music]
impressive yes I'd rather and see it
myself and dramatic cloak work
star shorts
is Anakin eating bugs a thing do they
just make that up or does he canonically
slurp down worms for fun
the following trailer is rated as for
spoilers but come on you know you've
already seen this movie
[Music]
from the company that owns everything
you know and love and diet Spielberg
comes a movie that had to satisfy
Decades of pinup nerd expectations make
up for the prequels introduce the
franchise to a new generation of fans
make enough money to justify Disney's
four billion dollar Investments and also
you know be good so no pressure Star
Wars the Force awakens
the force has awakened and its first
order is to revitalize the franchise
while setting the stage for an amazing
expansion of the Star Wars Cinematic
Universe by shamelessly remaking A New
Hope what the who are you I'm the
original honest trailer voice and the
originals are always better yeah you
wish now pipe down I've got the best
movie of the year to talk about best oh
man I'm not going anywhere someone has
to stop you from going full Fanboy oh
I've got a bad feeling about this all
your favorite characters are back for
another adventure Leia Chewie Han and
they all look really old uh okay but
these Living Legends are passing the
torch to a new generation of Heroes like
Rey and orphan scavenger who's so poor
she has to make her own Star Wars action
figures she's a multilingual expert
mechanic slash Ace pilot slash Force
using badass who's so good at everything
it makes her character completely
uncompelling how dare you I mean come on
how is she so good at everything because
you know she has the force and it's
Awakening and the force makes you
awesome
that's not how the force Works shut up
Han Solo God but Rey is not the only one
obsessed with Star Wars meet kylo Ren a
brooding Jedi Outcast torn between his
family Legacy and the dark side never
before has Star Wars had a villain so
layered so complex and so whiny he acts
like a goth kid who can't find his
eyeliner you know what If You're Gonna
Keep butting in why don't you just take
over now we're talking gear up for a
film so desperate to recapture the magic
of the first Star Wars it practically is
the first Star Wars featuring a desert
orphan finding a cute Droid with top
secret information who escapes the
Empire thanks to the Millennium Falcon
visits a shady Cantina learns about the
force from a tiny Alien watches a man in
Black kill her Mentor then helps destroy
a Death Star by deactivating a shield
generator so that x-wings can make a
trench run it's another desk star oh man
but it's so much more than a rehash of
everything that made a New Hope great
it's got all new stories to tell like
Finn a conflicted first order
Stormtrooper turned Rebel hunky badass
Poe Tamarin and don't forget Captain
phasma an awesome looking Stormtrooper
Commander who's completely wasted in
just 91 seconds of screen time that end
with her useless character getting
thrown in the garbage yeah they totally
wasted green of Tarth but get ready to
speculate as Abrams plants the seeds of
questions that will drive fans wild with
anticipation like who is snoke who are
Rey's parents and why does R2D2 suddenly
wake up plus questions that will annoy
the rest of the fans like why does R2D2
suddenly wake up why is everyone in the
Galaxy either a Skywalker or a solo and
why would we expect the guy who made
loss to have good answers for any of
these questions where'd you get that
good question for another time man is
there anything we can agree on about
this movie I don't know how about on the
count of three we name our favorite
Parts ready one two
three Kyle already stop the Blaster bolt
flying through a crash Star Destroyer
Poe dameron's beautiful face
okay now least favorites
after Han Solo dies did we just become
best friends yes story lay AARP Mary Sue
better Anakin
fn2187 hey that's my PIN number Han Polo
Emperor Voldemort R2D2 2 Han so long a
waste of the perfectly good The Raid
cast the easiest money Mark Hamill ever
made and butthole eyes Star Wars A
Familiar hope
well nice meeting you other epic voice
guy May the voice be with you hey guys
any reason why you didn't invite me who
are you I voiced the first ever honest
trailer remember in 3D Hey guys don't
forget about me I did Avatar oh man I
love how you said Blues
Blues Blues please
sir guys I heard you were having a voice
party how'd you all get in here I got
some pizza rolls in my underwear if you
want some maybe you should consider
locking your booth warning the following
video contains spoilers for rogue one a
Star Wars story
guys you've seriously got to learn how
to spell Rogue
[Music]
remember a new hope you remember Darth
Vader now prepare to remember the
handful of years between the rise of
Darth Vader and the start of a new hope
we call it a death star oh they're gonna
just rehash everything from Star Wars
aren't they I've got a bad feeling about
it
Rouge one a Star Wars story
get ready for Disney's first Star Wars
Anthology movie because there's no way
in hell they'd call it Star Wars prequel
number four in what has to be the most
money anyone's ever spent to fill in a
plot hole that's the place I've laid my
trap
that answers your most pressing
questions how exactly did the rebels get
the plans to the Death Star did they
grab a data tape with a giant claw
machine then use a big antenna to beam
the data tape to a ship and then did
that ship transfer the data to another
smaller tank and then to Princess Leia
cubby that's Marty onto a tiny droid's
hard drive you know whoever said this
one is as good as Empire must be really
into file formats
meet an all-new gang of rebels you uh
how do I put this shouldn't get too
attached to
like Jen or so the rebellious Rebel who
rebelled so hard she does whatever her
dad tells her
right I know we will whatever her
surrogate dad tells her go with him Jay
whatever her new co-worker tells her I'm
coming
but sometimes she's pretty grumpy about
it hmm rebelling alongside Jin is k2so a
Droid with more personality than any of
the human characters I'll be there for
you Cassian said I had to
Cassian a rebel whose most heroic moment
comes when he doesn't murder someone for
once I had every chance to pull the
trigger but did I saw Guerrera an
extremist cast out of the alliance by
extensive reshoots
the blind guy who's technically not a
Jedi but I mean come on look at this guy
and his friend uh gunny shoot face
I'd add more but that's pretty much all
there is to this guy
power before the might of the Empire as
various old dudes squabble over who gets
credit for the Death Star we stand here
amidst my achievement not yours while
down on the battlefield Stormtroopers
are rolling out in two brand new flavors
but with the same old incompetence we're
used to whether they're missing easy
shots
casually getting taken out
setting up their weakness to sticks that
the Ewoks would take advantage of
[Music]
why do they even bother with the armor
at all
enjoy one of the most beautiful Star
Wars films today that feels like the
world's biggest budget fan film
full of Easter eggs that will have Die
Hard fans saying gold leader red leader
awesome the Guardians of the wheels I
get that reverence hey it's prequel guy
blue milk cool why does nobody ever tell
me anything okay I like them
you just [ __ ] yourself so that's where
those Cantina guys were they were
walking around yeah the t-15s have been
marked obsolete t15s yeah I'm gonna have
to look that one up later whoa what an
awesome way to put Tarkin in the uh
never mind and this feels wrong somehow
but nothing will service fans harder and
faster than Darth freaking Vader as a
much older sounding James Earl Jones
tries to give us a new iconic scene be
careful not to choke on your aspirations
uh who let George Lucas write a line but
just when you think he's been wasted
extend your lightsabers for the most
badass Star Wars moment put to film the
hallway scene
which makes Vader's next fight in the
timeline even sillier than it already
was
thank you
do more tricks
not storing the following shots you saw
in the trailers that weren't in the
movie Jin versus a TIE fighter the group
working together actual high stake
war-torn scarif this iconic shot of gin
undercover unused fader saw Guerrero's
other haircut the shot they based the
whole marketing campaign on all these
other cool shots and this line This is a
rebellion isn't it
I Rebel Okay cutting that would make
sense
Suicide Squad and unnecessary Star Wars
story
is with me I'm one with a force and a
forces with me that's not how the force
works
[Music]
[Music]
in a polarized world the next
installment of the franchise all about
balance and non-attachment will be
worshiped hated and obsessed over until
it's not even fun to talk about anymore
this is not going to go the way you
think nah we know Star Wars fans by now
Star Wars The Last Jedi
forget the Love Letter to The Originals
that was the force awakens because
episode 8 subverts everything you've
come to expect making it the worst one
ever uh who invited the original honest
trailer voice back are you really gonna
do the old ones or better Slash new ones
or better thing we did with the force
awakens the only way to talk about Star
Wars now is in absolutes so yes kinda
sithy of you but fine making Last Jedi a
refreshing update to a predictable
formula that spits in the face of
everything you once loved weiner traitor
me the new class of Heroes coming into
their own like Rey who after being
called by Luke's lightsaber is called by
the Jedi text called by a big wet hole
and called by her greatest friend of me
foreign
yet still gets zero answers to any of
her questions I thought I'd find answers
here I was wrong Poe who grows from a
hot shot sexy pilot to a treasonous
failure with more blood on his hands
than the Empire first order same
difference and Finn who went from a
deserter running away from the war to a
deserter running away from the war with
the help of newcomer Rose he'll learn to
put the greater good above himself
thanks to a pointless side quest to
Casino Royale because how dare they
spend 15 minutes connecting the action
to a larger theme the larger theme being
is it possible to miss pod racing I
didn't think so but here we are but
forget about the butt hurt Fanboys who
were just mad the movie isn't closer to
the one they wrote In Their Heads hey
because they're still all the old
favorites like Leia a battle hardened
General trying to keep the spark of hope
and she's in a coma Chewbacca who gets
nothing to do and Luke Skywalker who
after sad old Han and sad old Leia
really drives home how your heroes are
all sad and old now he's turned his back
on the franchise after watching the
prequels the legacy of the Jedi is
failure and not even reruns of A New
Hope can change his mind
because what Star Wars fans really
needed was to see their Idol throw his
lightsaber away like it was some kind of
joke and Star Wars is not a joke to me
yeah I've been meaning to talk to you
about Ryan Johnson ruined my childhood
like he ruined the laws of space battle
there are no laws to space battle there
should be luke isn't the only Skywalker
who has issues with the franchise kylo
Ren is back and he's demanding a full
reboot but the past died kill it if you
have to when he doesn't look like he's
about to cry which is always
[Music]
watch as he ditches the Vader Fanboy act
the Mighty Duck mask and his shirt
[Music]
you distracted me on purpose too late
moving on get ready for truly unexpected
answers to the puzzles of episode 7 that
can only be answered by asking what are
the most disappointing answers to the
puzzles of episode 7 like who are Rey's
parents nobody who it's no some dead guy
and how did maskinata get Luke's
lightsaber it doesn't matter and you're
stupid for asking that after all the
hours of speculation and Analysis was
genuinely exhilarating whoa how do we
keep from a certain point of viewing
each other yeah we're both pretty big
Star Wars nerds huh so gear up for the
most divisive Star Wars film ever made
where Ryan Johnson either doesn't
understand the lore or you made the
first Star Wars movie that lives up to
the values it preaches instead of
endorsing royal bloodlines and Reckless
aggression okay enough division let's
say our favorite things about it on the
count of three one two three
guard how about Yoda hitting Luke with a
stick porks wait really yeah I'll own it
okay now least favorite although not
telling her plan I get knocking put down
a peg but come on they're taking
shuttles to a fort why make everyone
think they're gonna die I can't argue
with that though I'm sure people will
should we do this again for solo nah I'm
not gonna see that crap story after Star
Wars fan base
salt Blu-ray Luke T milker Kerry Poppins
Finn the Human I've Been Kissed by a
rose on the brain Kai's so serious
serious nope give me the cocking Keyshia
cocky Nerf herder Short Round
Pew Brienne of Darth hugs to be you
and Redemption for Star Wars kid
Star Wars the last one you'll pay to see
until the next one comes out
Maybe
it is time for my fandom to end did you
hear JJ finish the script for episode
nine my fandom is back temporarily
[Music]
you love the original trilogy with a
burning passion you went to war Over The
Last Jedi now get ready for a completely
new kind of Star Wars movie one you'll
forget by the time you're home from the
theater
solo a Star Wars story oh yeah that did
come out this year didn't it
after Disney re-shot half of their first
Star Wars story because they didn't like
what the director did watch them hand
the keys to an exciting new creative
team then reshoot even more of the movie
because they didn't like what the
directors did you're touchy resulting in
a mixed bag that wasn't exactly great
but wasn't exactly terrible and if
that's how Disney plans to bring balance
to the force just Sith me up fam
prepare for a feature-length adaptation
of Han Solo's Wikipedia page in a film
that's less a Han Solo character study
and more of an origin story for all of
Han Solo's accessories like his gun
[Music]
his ship the Millennium Falcon the
little notch in the ship what are you
doing that's the Escape pod
his favorite comeback I hate you
and of course his iconic dice
since when were the dye such a big deal
it was just a silly background prop not
everything needs an explanation
I don't have people I'm alone
um
solo no one asked for this
gear up with Alden ehrenreich a good
young actor is stuck with a thankless
job of playing a young Harrison Ford I
waited a long time for a shot like this
I'm not about to screw it up all right
he'll add New Dimensions to the selfish
Outlaw pilot we met in New Hope by
showing us he was never much of an
outlaw you are the good guy and he was
never really that selfish
but boy did he have a hard on for being
a pilot I'm gonna be a pilot I'm going
to be a pilot I swear to myself I've
become a pilot I'm a great pilot I'll be
your co-pilot we've already got the
pilot okay okay he wants to be a pilot
we get it already anything else what was
his dad like he wanted to be a pilot
never mind let's just go back to
learning about his accessories where'd
he get that vest
strap in his Han joins a gang of even
scruffier Nerf herders like Chewbacca
who hates people now
Beckett who acts a lot like Woody
Harrelson if he got trapped in the Star
Wars movie Kira who's working for Paul
Bettany but really working with Han but
really working with Darth Maul he can't
triple cross a double cross he can
triple cross a double cross valve the
coolest new Star Wars character
never mind Lando the Star Wars story
we'd all rather see except for that part
where he's clearly having sex with his
Droid
that works and l337 who is either an sjw
or an offensive satire of wokeness
depending on which part of the internet
you like to scream at
when Han Solo was the blandest character
in your Han Solo movie you've got a
problem I'm hot
nobody cares did you want a darker take
on the Star Wars franchise well you've
got it because this one is so dark it's
hard to see what's happening whether the
action is hidden in deep blues muted
Browns
a kind of drab Olive or Taco Bell beef
orange by the time your eyes adjust
you'll realize everyone in the galaxy is
lit like they're in witness protection
oh cool there's the Falcon I think man
this movie is literally the dark side so
catch the first flop of the Disney Star
Wars era that froze all the other
Standalone projects in carbonite but
gave bands a sense of how han became the
character we all know and love by going
through the events of solo
then at some point off camera before A
New Hope becoming the character we all
know and love Beckett said he heard
about this very big gangster putting
together a job so what was the point of
this movie again
starring Lone Star Harry and the
Harrelson's white man can't jump to
light speed Khaleesi the sentient being
trapped inside the Falcon yikes six
seasons in a Wookie I want Tandy name
this character you can't can you pirates
of the corellian Samus Aaron Terrace
Coffee that crappy PlayStation game is
Canon now
half the mole I used to be and Disney
every time they fire a director in the
middle of a production it's got a really
good feeling about this
Cowboy bee flop
um
solo you know if so isn't his birth name
why did he give it to his kid and then
name him after Luke's hermit friend who
he knew for like a day maybe no wonder
he tossed him off that bridge
[Music]
from Colin trevorrow until someone saw
the book of Henry and the director who's
never seen a landing he couldn't not
stick comes the Epic conclusion to the
force awakens Star Wars Episode 7.5 the
rise of Skywalker I got a bad feeling
about this The Last Jedi asked you to
forget everything you knew about Star
Wars so when some fans threw the kind of
fit usually reserve for ethics and games
journalism Disney panicked and tried to
mash the pieces back together in this
hollowed-out shell of a Trilogy that's
missing any consistency in its plot
themes or characters unless you fill in
the blanks on Twitter read all the
novels and happen to be running some
fortnite squads with the boys during the
crossover event the Day of Victory is at
hand the day of Revenge the day of the
Sith oh that's what the dead speak was
referencing fortnite side just like how
Return of the Jedi revealed the second
death star in root beer Tapper
[Music]
when we left them the resistance was
down to its last gasp and the first
order reigned Supreme now stuff has
happened and the resistance is back to
fighting strings while the first order
is taking loans from the rich old
grandpa they don't call anymore they'll
strike a dark bargain with the only
character left on the rotting carcass of
the original trilogy Palpatine or a
clone of him that's like rotting away
and snoke is also a clone and he's being
pickled I don't know not super clear the
emperor is enacting the same plan he had
last time troll a young Jedi into
striking him down break me down and your
journey towards the dark side will be
complete strike me down and my spirit
will pass into you and when that fails
hit him with the old zap hands
but luckily the same Luke Skywalker who
bailed in this whole mess also left a
scavenger hunt to stop him sending our
heroes running to find the thingy the
location of the wayfinder has been
inscribed upon this dagger that leads to
the other thingy the emperor's wayfinder
is in the Imperial Vault that leads to
the bad guy he's going to exigo she's
showing us how to get there well the
first order keeps sending them running
whenever some character growth is about
to happen there's an incoming Destroyer
gotta go now man
come on you know I've been thinking a
lot about this film and the biggest
issue it has at its core is oh no Tie
fighters everybody's Grand
all the new characters you still barely
know after three movies have returned
like Poe who I guess was a Smuggler at
some point your friend's old job was
running spice completing his org from
Han Solo type to just Han Solo Finn
who's still fighting Against All Odds to
keep himself in the movie I need to go
alone we go together we're all in this
gotta go after her
oh boss Kanata who snatched a medal out
of Leia's cold dead hands just a police
and 40 year old Fanboys these poor
Schmucks whose stories must have been
cut for time kylo Ren continuing the
Skywalker tradition of being a genocidal
death cultist who's Redeemed by a single
act of good and Rey who's taken Luke's
X-Wing his lightsaber his book
collection possibly his childhood home
and his last name Ray who Ray Skywalker
huh was Ray playing the long game
because I think Luke Just Got Talented
Mrs Ridley
don't like the newcomers don't worry no
one is ever really gone rejoin your old
Palace 3PO Chewie Luke Leia Han and
Lando who are so sidelined at this point
that one of them is fake memory wiped
memory restoration complete one of them
faked eyes
one of them thinks Last Jedi was for
fake fans only Jedi's weapon deserves
more respect one of them dies from
causing the fake death of her son
one of them died two movies ago and is
so over this franchise he wouldn't even
get a haircut to Cameo as a memory and
one of them is alive and well enough to
seemingly hit on his own daughter well
let's find out didn't know that's who
Janna was supposed to be it was in the
rise of Skywalker visual companion book
idiot you should have been reading that
in between rounds of fortnite you call
yourself a Star Wars fan
so strap in for a conclusion that brings
so much new to the franchise from the
new Force powers that would have really
come in handy for Qui-Gon Jin
to hammering at home that all these dead
Stormtroopers were actually kidnapped
children Harvest more of a Galaxy's
young to finally see the Knights of ren
do absolutely nothing then go out like a
bunch of weak ass punks
and mercifully brings the new Star Wars
cinematic era to a close with a sloppily
constructed hastily executed mess that
managed to do the impossible unite fans
Who Loved The Last Jedi and fans who
hated The Last Jedi by pleasing none of
them it's on fire
the whole thing's on fire
starring oh we're using our made-up
names then I'm Ray Skywalker hugged Finn
Narco Polo Gentle Ben use the force me
the only consistent character across all
nine films participation trophies Don't
Force so hard you'll end up just like
your brother an old man wearing the same
outfit he had in his 20s cut off my Mane
The Rocketeer rolling James Dio Tony
said cloned this in a cave Bland Moff
Tarkin a rose by any other name would
get to speak how can I be a mechanic I
have no arms Darth sibelius you know
what's cooler than one Captain phasma
six captain phasmas and Rey's dramatic
reveal phase
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Star Wars Episode 9 the last Star Wars
for a while at least they really need to
think this through
you know I'm starting to think it's a
bad idea for one Studio to make every
big movie I was cybernetically
engineered the pilot of spacecraft for
cybernetically engineered to be a
douchebag but you do the choice what'd
you do to the Falcon Falcons all up in a
shape that he is bb8's not on fire
what's left of him isn't on fire
on your left
[Applause]
but there are more of us will look at
this
[Music]
[Music]
after Star Wars was ruined forever
thanks to the monsters at Disney Star
Wars will be unruined by an all-new
streaming series made by the monsters at
Disney I'm confused used do they hate us
or not this is the way
the Mandalorian
Anakin was supposed to bring balance
Luke should have saved the day and Rey
just ended up squatting at the farm of
her mentor's uncle that he hated and
couldn't wait to run away from sorry
sorry not today episode nine now as our
heroes fall one food truck Enthusiast
will rise Revitalize the franchise in
his VR garage and keep the empire in
business
with eight episodes of Western riffs
that got the fan base all up in their
feelings over a Muppet baby Kathleen
Kennedy more like crappling Kino
suit up within jorin AKA Mando which
starts to sound like a slur the more you
hear it hey Mando hand over the child
Mando get that blaster on my face
uh guys that's their word are you sure
we can use it
after the prequels literally ruin his
childhood follow this wandering Bounty
Hunter on a tale of redemption in
between a whole bunch of actual
wandering
foreign
foreign
as he Jets from exotic locales to less
exotic locales to a quick detour to most
Nostalgia to pick up delivery of Easter
eggs
Tuscan Raiders
but screw it how fun is it to dick
around in the Star Wars Universe without
some sad kid in their daddy issues
killing the vibe man everything will
change when this loan not a gungan
gunman maybe he's a gungan meets the
most adorable MacGuffin of all time the
child okay you know what we're not doing
that he's a baby Yoda we're calling him
baby Yoda
he's a magic puppet who can kill you
with cuteness
and if that doesn't work he can always
just kill you no no stop but one thing
is for certain he's not nearly as
precocious when they reveal he's
actually a middle-aged man they said 50
years old I'm on you baby Yoda you can
talk you're just some creepy Boomer with
a diaper fetish aren't you
I can't believe I let my kid play with
you saddle up for brand new Star Wars
Adventures the likes of which he'd never
seen before but don't freak out look
familiar stuff Tatooine classic
Stormtroopers good breathe good in this
tale of one man's Destiny to clear an
extremely low bar be the best single dad
in Star Wars but this father-son do
won't travel alone there's Quail who
finally gave a modern update to talk to
the hand I have spoken I have spoken I
have spoken Tobias funke's acting coach
you take this home throw it in a pot add
some broth a potato baby you got a stew
going and Cara Dune the ex-rebel with
less range than the guy in the helmet so
we're gonna build a trap we're gonna
need to dig real deep right here so that
when it steps in it drops together
they'll encounter scum villainy and the
best alternate Dimension cast of
Saturday Night Live with Horatio Sims
Brian forsane
Amy sadaris
Bill Burr
Richard ayawade
Jason Sudeikis
and your host Taiko waititi you have
suffered damage to your central
processing unit foreign
that was a joke
so strap in for a show that every level
of Star Wars fan can enjoy whether
you're Anew who just wanted to know why
baby Yoda was on your kids Christmas
list but stuck around because it
reminded you of the Searchers a casual
fan who spent Eight Episodes wondering
why Luke Skywalker wasn't in the Boba
Fett show or a hardcore nerd who needed
validation for keeping your toy
collection meant in box all these years
wait is that the imperial troop
transport of my youth it's it's
beautiful that owes its success to
telling a simple lean story about an
all-new family in the Star Wars universe
and because it was a hit they're
probably about to weigh it down with a
bunch of lore Crossovers and spin-offs
ah this is the way
starring Dark Helmet I'm 50. baby you've
got a rudely stew going MMA Los Pollos
imperiales Warner Herzog as himself I
see nothing
but death and Chaos
I would like to see the baby yeah Satan
I'm sorry sir you sounded like someone
else the babysitter clubs
the outer Skyrim how do you like the
Maddox huh Boba feed let's make the baby
do the magic hand thing come on baby do
the magic hand thing that's not how the
magic hand thing works nerds of the
round table and when my friends ask what
fastball song we're listening to this is
the way this is the way this is the way
this is the way this is the way this is
the way this is the way
the out rim job
and once again the Galaxy is a mostly
mechanic bounty hunting and
cantina-centric economy no one's ever a
real estate agent in these things
marketing somehow the Star Wars Universe
remains dentist free don't they have
teeth
foreign
s in outer burbankia come season two of
a show that's either the greatest thing
we've ever seen or live action Star Wars
has lowered our expectations so much
basic competence feels like seeing the
face of God it's glorious
the Mandalorian season two
suit up for more Mandalorian the show
that combined the world of Star Wars the
feel of old Samurai films and the
emotional core of reddit's r slash all
community
oh in a winning mix that keeps things
simple and doesn't overstay its welcome
so you can be sure as Sith they'll
launch enough spin-offs to Kill the
Magic for good next year you know
there's a reason we don't eat birthday
cake every day Disney keep feeding us
the same thing and we will reject it
unless it's Marvel or animated musicals
or Pixar movies about giving up on your
dreams okay fine you win stuff my mouth
full of cake Mouse daddy
rejoin the Mandalorian the Galaxy's most
dangerous never nude but this time he'll
break his only rule about giving face as
a quest to deliver this tiny meme
generator over to a Jedi all while
bonding ever deeper with baby Yoda over
their shared love of murder
oh
no no no
and yes we know his name isn't
technically baby Yoda anymore Kroger but
let's stick with baby Yoda grogu baby
Yoda grogu baby Yoda
he's the secret love child of Yoda and
yada okay clap them cheeks Yoda dude
cannon that is are you ready to watch
some space cops make some deals with
each other then you'll thrill when Mando
makes a deal with this Marshall help me
kill it I'll give you the Armor deal and
strikes a deal with the Tuscan Raiders
for help we have struck a deal but when
a deal goes wrong on the way to finding
a Jedi lady the deal is off this was not
part of the deal he'll try to forge a
deal with some fellow mandalorians
they're changing the terms of the deal
and got a quick deal with mingna I owe
you from last time we have a day off
before he wraps up that deal with her
and Boba Fett then our deal is complete
that's in addition to any bargain's
promises or propositions who make along
the way we can strike a bargain you made
me a promise and I held up my end I have
a proposition that may interest you then
what's in it for me screw credits the
real currency of Star Wars is the pinky
swear remember all the interesting and
original Side characters you met last
season they're back at least for now but
they'll make room for all new faces and
by new I mean really old like the most
popular characters from the Clone War
series the most popular character from
Empire Strikes Back and the most popular
character from Star Wars
it's official no one in Star Wars gets
to die or retire anymore this season's
most meaningful death was when they
killed off a merchandising opportunity
so enjoy this action-packed journey
alongside a hardened killer with a heart
of gold and a soft baby with a Heart of
Darkness as favro and felony deliver the
second best Star Wars experience ever
made for television
but you all know what's still number one
[Music]
no not Clone Wars
no not Rebels I'm talking about the
intro to the droids cartoon come on
[Music]
trouble again
oh man that's such a Bop
starring
Daft Punk my buddy my buddy wherever I
go he goes Ranger of the new Republicans
Dawson's geek Princess Leia agents of
Shand lone wolf with Club moth diver
darkness no parents Red Sox leader
standing by Goo
Stormtroopers giving themselves away
over there all right we'll check it out
securities
best gore best car's value continues to
rise colors with best car have been
through here the best car belongs to the
mandalorians it cannot cut through pure
baskar is ours fiscal this car pure best
car unreasonably convenient maps and
blueprints this is a map of Tatooine
before the war you got most Eisley most
espa and up and up in this region most
Helga were here this entire area is the
green zone completely safe but over on
this side is the problem this is what
you're talking about right yeah it's the
refinery right there they're held in
Cold Storage in this cargo bay
it's not the scale I think it is
it can't be this too big if your 98
Civic hatchback was a spaceship
and my deep fake kills other Doors Down
the guard
the masked Slinger
says here you're from Alderaan
did you lose anyone
[Music]
uh yeah Chief I'm gonna guess you did
[Music]
from the company that knows you like
Star Wars so they put a little Star Wars
on the Star Wars Hub so you can watch
Star Wars Before The Next Star Wars
comes out comes what any responsible
content Factory would do and outsources
the job to Asia in these non-canon
Japanese short films that would all make
for a better movie trilogy than the one
we just got somehow Palpatine returned
and yes I'm including the furry episode
in fact especially the furry episode
here are all nine animated shorts from
Star Wars Visions
from the studio that's probably gonna
make Optimus Prime a Shogun next comes a
General Grievous level circle jerk of
influences in this Kurosawa influence
Star Wars influenced by the Star Wars
most influenced by Kurosawa again it's
like poetry so if they rhyme we're a
rodent battles Lucy Liu for the fate of
a small feudal Village but only after
his Droid gets hurt he couldn't give a
[ __ ] before that that
how dare you bedroy was wearing a hat
Ronin holiday
in a world where the most popular music
on the planet is called jizz prepare for
the only genre that's even less
appealing mid-2000s pop punk in this
extremely straightforward story about a
band that gets broken up by chibi Boba
Fett and immediately reunites because
any more story would take time away from
Joseph Gordon-Levitt singing
this is what happens when an anime
doesn't get eight minutes of opening
credits they just drop it into the
episode
blink 2187 get ready for an episode that
feels like it was inspired by The Last
Jedi why you like it I swear featuring
more neon than a Batman Forever street
gang that shows off what's possible when
you go all anime no breaks with the
visuals but still honors the prequel
trilogy by having horrible stilted
dialogue
Bravo Allison Brie you act you act as
hard as you can and evil twins when a
village is threatened by Raiders wait
didn't we see this one already oh
different village okay when another
Village is threatened by Raiders it will
take one masterless Jedi teaming up with
an anti-master it doesn't suit you that
musk to help two orphans link their
majinas
Gina by slicing up Imperial scar with a
katana saber and some sweet tactical
high heel shoes wait didn't we see a
lady Force user in heels already is that
so they always have The High Ground
Wedding Crashers witness assured that
packs so much World building imagination
and likable characters into 20 minutes
you won't even care that they ran out of
creativity for the names greetings my
name is Ethan as a Young Apprentice gets
trapped in a temple full of Sith who
wants to steal her custom lightsabers
even though all you have to do to get
one is download the saber Pass App the
week before you go to the planet then
sign up using the saber magic system to
book your sabersovation so that when you
do arrive at the temple all you need to
do is check in get your saber band while
the QR code on saber pass then report to
the lightsaber store at 300 credits to
your mysaber account and get in the two
hour Reserve cue simple
my saber Totoro
from the team that made Space Dandy
[Music]
all right comes baby's first star war
about a Droid who was built to sit in a
small room and do math but also given
feelings of love boredom and frustration
because Star Wars loves to remind us
that droids are slaves
your your name is Toby Pinocchio
from the people who also made the psycho
one about the evil twins comes the Star
Wars application of a Clint Eastwood
movie as a salty old Jedi Warrior since
his assistant of a dang Mountain to face
a sid while he hangs out of base camp
too make sure he didn't double back aha
that ends with the Jedi pretending to be
dead then ganging up in an old man while
they're distracted
this is also supposed to be heroic
elder abuse
blast off to the zootopia system for 20
minutes that will Delight everyone from
anime fans to Star Wars fans to furries
and yes I'm aware that being a fan of
one significantly raises your chances of
being the other two in this heartwarming
Saga of a father having to decide which
of his daughters will inherit the family
lightsaber the tiny two with a heart of
gold or the evil human who uses her own
blood as eyeliner do you want pink eye
because that's the other way to get pink
eye bunny Heist
from still Japan but with a few pieces
of African Flair comes a really annoying
road trip across the planet of the tiny
mouths in a classic tale of how when a
Jedi falls in love everything turns to
sh yep even in an anime they're creepy
sexless monks who are only allowed to
play with their own lightsabers
literally Star Wars visions
starring when you all copied off the
same kit for your test I got a bad
feeling about this you have a bad
feeling about this I have a bad feeling
about this you've got a bad feeling
about this I've got a bad feeling about
this and more Crystal talk than a white
girl's apartment if you use the power of
the kyber crystal the crystal is the
core of the lightsaber crystals Crystal
Crystal Crystal crystals
star weeb content
okay how is there not a short word Luke
Skywalker is the principal at a high
school for French maids I figure at
least one Anime Studio would have had
that idea
[Music]
he was the best part of the holiday
special which isn't saying much
but ever since Boba Fett stood around
looking cool fans wanted to know more
and as we all know learning more about a
Star Wars character only makes them
cooler foreign
super duper cool I'm a person and my
name is Anakin
the book of Boba Fett
you remember him as the mysterious
Bounty Hunter with just four lines in
the original trilogy and that was
probably enough because now fans are
getting the show they dreamed of and
then it's literally full of naps
as Boba fulfills his Destiny and becomes
a fleshy ball that floats in Milky water
and when you're not watching an old man
take a bath or talking about taking one
I know you're a nice long soak in the
back to tank when this is done you'll
drift off to sleep during one of his
many soaks because as it turns out Boba
Fett has to think about his whole life
before he becomes crime Lord flashback
to that time Boba went out like an
absolute charm
and solved the mystery of how he
survived the sarlacc pit
he crawled out oh then fill in the
blanks of an entire lifetime of failure
and be downs from tuscans
to Wookies
to really just whoever
as this bumbling oh gets his friends
killed takes revenge on the wrong people
the one that massacred your Tuscan
family and blame it on a speed bike gang
and Feist to protect a city that also
would have killed his saviors if they
had the chance don't worry he fails at
that too
nothing is here folks move along just
Bubba bet protecting your homes and
places of business don't forget to tip
your dime yo thrill as Boba replaces all
his dead friends with new ones who have
no choice but to hang out with him like
Phoenix Shan a cool assassin he is the
guilt and bribe into joining his crew I
saved your life two body Hogs who have
to be his friend or die would you be
loyal to me if I were to spare you
and this badass tree gang of
these badass kids
sorry are those Vespas I I can't I I
can't take them seriously so by now if
you're thinking this blows can we watch
something else Disney is way ahead of
you as the show hard pivots into the
Mandalorian phew catch up with Mando
chopping up bounties with a lightsaber
even though he doesn't meet the stat
requirements it gets heavier with each
move tricks out a sweet new Hot Rod she
used to fly a razor crest
and makes tiny little shirts for his
little bitty Beanie Baby oh then oh even
more at the return of baby Yoda who's
still so cute he offsets the bad vibes
coming from Luke deepaker a short time
for you is a lifetime for someone else
and sure grogu and Dan bail on their
missions and character arcs to help out
Boba but desperate times call for
desperate measures and who boy does this
show need reinforcements no one respects
you okay Ahsoka you're up earlier than
we thought Ted Bane get your blue ass in
here all hands on deck people it's an
after-school special down there this is
a Dexter Jester level emergency thank
you manners
I like it we're too late abort
get to learn so much more and understand
so much less about Tatooine a planet
Luke once assured us was very boring but
since there's a wild Metropolis full of
spaceports casinos and teenage cyborgs
five minutes from Beggars Canyon
now it just seems like Luke wanted to
join the Empire I want to transmit my
application to the academy this year
it's here in the most remote corner of
the center of the Galaxy where Boba will
become the daimyo a mob boss like Jabba
the Hutt except this crime Lord won't
accept protection money I asked for no
tribute or kill people shall I kill him
no or rough them up I do not touch you
or steal things we stole it that's a
crime or demand a meeting it was a bit
heavy-handed don't you think do you want
the appointment or not Eddie definitely
says no to drugs there's a lot of
credits to be made from that orange
powder spice is killing our people even
though he had his whole life changed
from chasing brain dust with a nose
lizard
you know I'm starting to think a crime
story on a children's network was a bad
idea I would
do this so break out your slaying
protocol Droid oh he's singing like a
yellow
there's a Gunk skunk Jack if that's not
the quack to call in the stifling slimy
and slip into a nice warm bath until we
get a proper third season of the
Mandalorian because this show is 50
dramatic entrance
foreign
[Music]
what an entrance and that other 50 you
guessed it space meetings do you have an
appointment
seeks an audience with you do they have
an appointment
please come in have a seat arrange a
meeting with the mayor mayor won't have
a meeting
I'm here to make a proposal that's
mutually beneficial
[Music]
starring stop trying to make fit happen
I like shine she's soft and smooth and
helpful she kills everyone Libra
Groundhog Day that's where you know this
guy from we gave a Wookie brass knuckles
and got him drunk you'll totally believe
what happened next
Princess Vespa iRobot that'll do pigs
that'll do I've whipped my Tails back
and forth I put my Tails back and forth
what beat boobs in the shadows my child
is an honor student at Skywalker Jedi
Academy the Dropout you don't have to be
lonely at Joe isonly.com Timothy
olliefand Timothy elephant CAD bod well
Chate in space
and twins I find your smooth at face
disturbing and if you want to be a
badass you got to learn to fight with a
stick
foreign
there's nothing now but will someday be
a great School
Grogan will be its first student
amazing every word of what you just said
was wrong
[Music]
now the George Lucas cashed out and
Disney turned the franchise into FIFA
with lightsabers open wide as they Chuck
another hunk of content on the rancor
pit of Disney Plus
what
this was actually pretty tasty
[Music]
Obi-Wan Kenobi
you had to watch Han Solo turn into a
broke divorced dad you had to watch Luke
Skywalker become a gross recluse now
it's Obi-Wan Kenobi's turn to go down
bad and this Legend from the prequels
and original trilogy and Clone Wars
becomes a sad fishmonger who everyone
Rose like Anakin on beach day
the years have made you weak and the
next nine years are gonna suck even more
prepare for a show that reminds you how
great the prequels were when they're cut
down to a three-minute recap montage and
cheer is the best part of those films
returns
hello Dex follow along on the celibate
religious man's new Mission stare at a
ten-year-old boy all day but when a
special little princess gets moved to
another Castle Obi will have to save a
Skywalker for the upteenth time even
though he's forgotten his super speed
forgotten how twins work how old are you
and forgotten how to hide like at all
hey uh you gonna change your last name
Buddy maybe dye your hair I don't know
stop wearing Jedi robes that's not an
improvement you look like Vincent adult
man hello other grown-up
thrill at the latest installment of Star
Wars babies Leia Edition Vivian Blair
shines as a young princess with more
sass than Carrie Fisher if she were
actually born into royalty if anyone
asks you're my daughter granddaughter
maybe what nothing and once this Lone
Wolf and Cub link up you're in for yet
another round of grumpy Warrior gets a
cute sassy kid to safety but hey if it
ain't broke don't fix it hello there
again Ewan
lead a Galaxy's worth of supporting
characters some of whom don't even live
on Tatooine
like a guy who puts the mid and
midichlorians oh judgmental an imperial
officer who's not like those other
Imperials she feels bad about it I
joined up when the Empire stood for
something
with some mistakes and evil Twisted
villains like modern Star Wars fandom if
you're sending her bullying messages
you're no Star Wars fan in my mind Riva
a youngling who never finished her
grooming but graduated with honors from
the loud quiet loud again School of
villainy tell me where the Jedi is what
makes you think
you won't see it coming send out the
probes do it
and of course Darth Vader who's now
literally a mix of man and machine
hating Christensen kills it in a dual
role as both the guy in the Big D suit
and his Anakin and his seventh senior
year at Jedi Academy he'll give us fresh
insight into Vader's loss of humanity
and show us what really turned Annie to
the dark side you don't need to prove
yourself as your undoing until you
overcome it a padawani will still be
here so to prove himself worthy of being
a Jedi Anakin had to try his hardest to
stop trying so hard to prove himself
worthy of being a Jedi okay this scene
makes sense now
foreign
the weird new Middle Ground of Star Wars
that looks bad for a movie but good for
a TV show too short for a series but too
long for a film incredible lightsaber
duels but Rinky Dink says
and a story constrained by the trilogies
that take place before and after but
drops enough breadcrumbs to launch a
rogue squadron's worth of future Star
Wars content
let's get started I think I had a
brother I think I've just found out what
they're hiding down here okay none of
those Jedi are actually dead Disney just
Jurassic Park them until it's their turn
for a show
starring Gentle Ben
Problem Child that's what I love about
these younglings man I get older they
stay the same age Neon Genesis
revengelean I don't like sand snacks the
coarse and rough and irritating he
doesn't even go here hashtag Justice for
hat we only sell moisture here where the
Jedi round back whoops hold my beiru
what I got I Gotta Give it to ariva cool
male none Jedi nice Cube and the one
lesson Disney can't afford to learn it's
the past move on be done with it
Ben Hur
so Reba's plan was to work her way up to
Grand Inquisitor then just try to stab
Darth Vader in the back
probably gonna see that one coming it's
literally the only way Sith get promoted
[Music]
you love the Mandalorian you liked most
of Kenobi and Boba Fett exists I know
you're a nice long soak in the back to
tank when this is done now Disney's got
a new Star Wars streaming show that fans
never asked for in this prequel of a
prequel about the third lead in Rogue
one and it's the best thing they've ever
made this show does not brown
and or
experience a Galaxy that looks different
from the one we're used to because it
wasn't shot in The Giant Egg where
Disney makes everything else in the
first Star Wars streaming show free from
cheap nostalgia
[Music]
merchandising bait Jedi Sith lightsaber
Skywalkers the force Tatooine or comedy
[Music]
honestly it's hard to believe it's in
the same universe as all the other crap
those of you who
used when we enter this building we are
in
emergency powers to the Supreme
Chancellor
all right
Diego Luna is back as Cassian and or a
human board on planet orphan but who
grew up on ferricks a working-class town
with a strong commitment to the
percussive Arts
[Music]
when Cassian kills two cops outside of a
brothel
embark on his epic journey to be
anywhere other than where he is at any
moment I just think enough to get out of
I can't be here we need to go tomorrow
we're getting out of here we're leaving
I need to relocate for a while you gotta
get out of here I'm done come on guys
get your whole life ahead of you sit
down for once and enjoy a beautiful
sunrise with a loved one oh right
join the fight to take down the Empire
with the rebellion's goth space Uncle I
made my mind a sunless face stellen
scarsgard shines in his dual role as a
leader willing to sacrifice anything and
anyone and a sassy antique stealer who
lets his hands do the talking gift for
your husband I'll have some new things
coming in soon
[Music]
finding his operation is mon mothma a
galactic Senator with a relatable
problem she spent way too much money on
Star Wars how much is missing four
hundred thousand deeper in your
understanding of this original trilogy
briefings Giver as a key figure who
bankrolled the rebels at the sacrifice
of her family but like no big loss there
that's just so heartful go deep like
super deep into the inner workings of
the Empire with Cyril corn a mall cop
who accidentally kicks off the Rebellion
while his boss is away at a conference I
was a good Deputy inspector he's a
domineering little dweeb with mommy
issues been in my private box I have a
voice of knowing tricks are for kids mom
cringe has his Oedipus complex locks on
to Dedra Miro a high-ranking
intelligence officer with a mean case of
mean face
but that's not how you pictured
Jennifer's voice huh in a show with such
a deep Fascination and the banality of
evil and the complex inner workings of
bureaucracies you'll swear it was mainly
intended for adults have you saw New
Hope in theaters you're 50 it's time
thrill at a show that puts characters
first but still propelled By
multi-episode plot arcs like a heist
that sets Cassian up as more young
Stalin than young solo cassin's Hometown
being slowly ground down under the
Empire's boot until the little dick
Droid that could tips the scales
oh no it's odd
and a three episode Prison Break
sequence starring Andy Circus that is so
[ __ ] good he needs to hang up the
mocap suit immediately this man has
earned the right to use his own human
face forever just the best
so forget all your expectations about
Star Wars and Disney plus and prepare to
learn what the Rebellion against the
empire actually demanded of its
Believers their freedom their souls
their very lives and 7.99 a month until
Disney actually makes season two you
better leave the show alone Disney
there's only one force corporate
crossover will accept one yeah but I've
always wanted to touch him I like the
texture of Yaba is something I need to
discover then I'm obsessed with the
texture of java I'm very curious to
actually touch that texture I've been
dreaming
his skin is just something that obsesses
me touching is you know like his belly
like I'm not in love with Java that was
one big mistake I made but I have like
seven yavas at home
starring San Diego
Baron starkin in the moon don't trust
the ISB in division 23.
drop that zero and get captured by Miro
The Hive rise up going forward to build
a breakthrough Empire 2.0 and succeed in
an increasingly competitive world we
will need to be extremely hardcore
Caesar the means of production
from the Nook of Saul and cousin
Empire Records
everything you need here is on the wall
water night light and fun
you can get as much as you want top
table wins flavor wait water and food
tubes right next to my bed and sometimes
the food tube has flavor that's
downright luxurious by my standards
oh this is genius